alright let's get started so we're gonna
continue talking about Bayesian networks
which we started on Monday and just a
kind of quick recap we've been talking
about Bayesian networks which is a new
paradigm for defining models and what is
a Bayesian network you have a set of
variables which are nodes in a graph for
example whether you have a cold way they
have allergies where you're coughing
whether you have itchy eyes these nodes
are related by a set of directed edges
which capture various dependencies for
example itchy eyes is caused by
allergies but not cold or bike off and
then formally for every variable in the
Bayesian network you have a local
conditional distribution which specifies
the distribution over that variable
given the parents so the parents of
cough are cold and allergies so it you
would have a local conditional
distribution of P of H given CNA you do
that for all the variables and finally
you take all the factors or a local
conditional distribution and you
multiply them together and you can one
glorious joint distribution over all the
possible variables in your distribution
okay so in other words to sum it up you
can think about Bayesian networks as
factor crafts plus probability they
allow you to define ginormous joint
distributions over lots of random
variables using factor graphs which
allow you to specify things very
compactly and moreover we saw glimpses
of how we can use the structure of
factor graphs to permit efficient
inference so probabilistic inference in
bayesian networks is the task of given a
Bayesian network which is you know this
Oracle about the what you know about or
the world and you look at some evidence
that you've found so it's you know it's
raining or not raining or or you have
itchy eyes or so on and you condition on
that evidence and you also have
set of query variables that you're
interested in asking about and the goal
is to compute the probability of the
query variables condition on the
evidence that you see big e equals
literally remember Laura uppercase is
random variables lower case is is actual
values and so for example in the
coughing case there's the probability of
a cold given the fact that you're
coughing but don't have a chi is okay
and this problem this probability is
defined by just the laws of probability
which we went over the first slide of
last lecture and the challenge is how to
do this efficiently okay and that's
going to be the topic of this so any
questions about the basic setup of what
Bayesian networks are and how do you
what is mean to do for all the skin
friends okay one maybe kind of a
high-level note about Bayesian networks
is that I think they're really powerful
as a way to describe time knowledge I
think a lot of AI today is focused on
particular tasks where you define some
output inputs and you define some
outputs and you train a classifier and
the classifier that you train can only
do this one thing input output but the
paradigm behind Bayesian networks and
databases in general is that you have
developed a kind of knowledge source
which can be probabilistic it's captured
by this Joint Distribution and once you
have it you use those tools of
probability to allow you answer an
arbitrary questions about it so you can
give me any pieces of evidence and any
query and it's clear what I meant to do
I'm supposed to compute these values so
this it's kind of a more flexible and
powerful paradigm than just you know
converting inputs outputs and so that's
why I think it's so interesting okay so
today we're going to focus on how to
compute these arbitrary inference query
efficiently I'm gonna start with
forward-backward and particle filtering
these are going to specialize to the
specific Bayesian networks called HMMs
hidden Markov models and then we're
going to look at Gibbs sampling which is
a much you know more general way of
doing things okay so a hidden Markov
model which I talked about last time
which we're going to go in more detail
at this time is a Bayesian network where
there exists a sequence of hidden
variables and a corresponding sequence
of observed variables so as a kind of
motivating example imagine you're
tracking some sort of object in your
homework you'll be tracking cars so H is
going to be the location of the object
or car at a particular time step I and
II I is going to be some sort of sensor
reading that you get at that particular
time step it could be the location plus
some noise or some sort of distance to
that the true object and so on okay so
these are the variables and you know it
goes well it's saying that the hidden
variables are hidden and the observed
variables are observed
so the distributions over this all the
variables is specified by three types of
local conditional distributions the
first one is just the starting
distribution what is the probability of
h1 this could be a uniform over all
possible locations just as an example
and then we have the transition
distributions which specify what is the
distribution over a particular hidden
variable the location of the true
location of object h i given h i minus 1
so this captures dynamics of how this
object or car might move over time for
example it could just be a uniform over
adjacent locations right so cars can't
teleport they can only move to adjacent
locations over a one time step and
finally we have emission distributions
which govern how the
sensor reading is computed as a function
of the location okay so this again could
be something as simple as uniform over
adjacent locations if you expect to see
some noise in your sensor the sensor
doesn't tell you where exactly the car
is but tells you approximately where the
car is and the Joint Distribution over
all these random variables is going to
be given by simply the product of
everything you see on the board I'm just
gonna write this up on the board just
for reference so we have the probability
of H equals H so this when I write H
equals H that means that h1 through hm
so all the random variables all the
hidden random variables all the observed
random variables and this is my
definition equal to the the start
distribution okay so start distribution
over h1 and then I have the transitions
I equals 1 I guess to 2n okay so this is
the probability of H I given H I minus 1
and then finally I have for every time
step I through one through n I have the
probability of observation given H I so
multiply all these factors together that
gives me a single number that is the
probability of all the observed and all
the hidden variables any questions about
the definition of a hidden Markov model
okay so given we have one of these
models remember with a Bayesian network
I can answer any sort of queries I can
ask what is the probability of H 3 given
H 2 and E 5 and I can do so all sorts of
crazy things and all these things are
possible and efficient to your compute
but we're gonna focus on two main types
of questions I'm motivated by the let's
say object tracking or example the first
question is filtering filtering says
you're in a particular time step let's
say time step 3
what what do I know about the true
object location H 3 given all the
evidence I've seen up until now so this
is kind of a real time object tracking
at each point in time you look at all
the evidence and you want to know where
the object is a similar question is
smoothing and you're still looking at a
particular time step 3 let's say but
you're conditioning on all the evidence
so you're looking at all the
observations and you're looking at
you're kind of thinking about this more
retrospectively where was object where
was object at time step 3 so think about
if you're trying to reconstruct the
trajectory or something ok so this is
called filtering and smoothing so let's
now try to develop an algorithm for
answering these type of queries and
without loss of generality I'm going to
focus on answering smoothing queries so
my why is it the case that if I tell you
I can solve all smoothing questions I
can also solve all filtering questions
so it is true so the this in filtering
this is us the evidence is a subset but
the answers are going to be different
depending on what evidence you computer
on so you can't literally just use one
as answer for the other yeah the lines
over the things that you eat for tea
yeah yeah
so you marginalize that so that's a key
idea is that suppose I had a smoother
and I wanted to answer this filtering
query right so this is H 3 given E 1 to
e 2 e 3 right remember last time we
talked about how you can take leaves of
bayesian networks which are not observed
and just essentially wipe them away so
if you don't observe a 45 h4 h5 you can
just pretend those things you know don't
exist right and now you're back to a
smoothing query where you're
conditioning on all the evidence ok so
we're gonna focus on smoothing and to
make a progress on this problem I'm
going to introduce a representation
that's going to help us think about the
possible assignments right and just to
be be clear right there's the reason why
this is not completely trivial is that
there are four if you have end hidden
variables there's to the N or x-men join
and number of possible assignments and
you can't just enumerate all of them so
you're going to have to come up with
some algorithm that can compute it more
efficiently ok so what we're gonna do is
introduce this lattice representation
which is going to give us a compact way
of representing those assignments and
then we can see how we can operate on
that representation ok so it's gonna
smell a lot like state based models so
we're kind of going backwards but
hopefully it'll make sense so the idea
behind a lattice representation is that
I'm going to have a set of rows and
columns so each column is going to
correspond to a particular variable so
the first column is going to correspond
to h1 and each row is going to
correspond to some setting of
that variable so there's two possible
things I can do I can either set h1
equals 1 or I can set each one equals 2
I'm the version I'm drawing on the board
is going to be a simplification of what
I have on the slides just such in the
interest of space and the second column
is going to be either h2 equals 1 or h2
equals 2 so by going through these all
lattice nodes which are drawn as boxes
I'm kind of assigning random variables
to a particular value okay so I'm gonna
connect these up so from this data I can
either set h2 equals 1 or 2 here I can
also go from 2 1 or 2 and finally let's
just do H 3 equals 1 H 3 equals 2 and
similarly I can choose either one of
them from no matter where I am and
finally I have an end State okay so
first notice that the size of the
lattice is reasonably well controlled
it's simply the number of time steps
times the number of values that a
variable can take on so let's suppose
that there's n time steps and K possible
let's say locations so values of H I so
how many nodes are here a times n right
ok so that means we can essentially this
doesn't blow up exponentially ok so now
let us interpret a path from start to
end what is a path from start to end
tell us so let's take let's take this
path now what are the what does this
tell us yeah
yeah it's a particular assignment of the
variable so this one says set H 1 2 1 H
2 2 1 H 3 2 1 this path says set H 1 2 2
h 1 2 1 and H 3 2 2 and so on ok so
every path from start to end is an
assignment to all the unobserved or
hidden variables ok so now remember each
assignment comes with some sort of
probability so we're gonna try to
represent those probabilities
I'm Chuck suppose on this graph ok so
I'm gonna go through each of these edges
so remember these are the probabilities
right so every assignment has is some
product of the factors and I'm going to
basically take these factors and just
sprinkle them on the edges at the points
where I can compute the factors and I'll
explain more what I mean by this
ok so so maybe one one kind of
preliminary thing I should mention is
suppose for this example we have we are
conditioning on e 1 equals 1 e 2 equals
2 let's say e 1 equals sorry 3 equals 1
okay so I'm conditioning on these things
notice I'm not drawing them in here
because these are observed variables I
don't have to reason about what values
they take on I'm only going to consider
the hidden variables which I don't know
but this is just going to be some sort
of reference ok so let's start with
start to H 1 equals 1 right so if you
remember back tracking and CSPs right we
basically took factors and then whenever
we could evaluate the factor we just put
it down on that edge in the backtracking
tree so here what what can we do we have
the probability of H 1 equals 1 ok and
then we also have the probability of the
first emission probability I can compute
right so that's a
probability of e 1 equals evidence I saw
which is 1 given H 1 equals 1 which is
the value that I've committed to here so
this is a number that is essentially the
weight or cost or score or whatever you
want to call it that a important to
incur when I traverse that edge ok so
what about this one so I have the
transition from let's say H 2 equals 1
given H 1 equals 1 and times the
probability of e 2 equals whatever I
observe which is 2 given H 2 equals 1
and similarly over here I have
probability of H 3 equals 1 given H 2
equals 1 times the probability of e 3
equals 1 which is whatever observed
given H 3 equals 1 and then over here
there's no more factors left so I'm just
going to put one there okay and you can
check that when I traverse this path and
I multiply all of these probabilities
together that's exactly this expression
for H 1 equals 1 H 2 equals 1 H 3 equals
1 e 1 equals 1 e 2 equals 2 e 3 and for
each of these edges I have an analogous
quantity depending on the values that
I'm dealing with ok any questions about
this basic idea so in the slides this is
basically what I just said ok so so now
now what I'm trying to do now is to
let's say I'm interested in you know
smoothing so I'm interested in what is
the probability of H 3 equals 2 right
actually let's let's do the example on
the board just just
because that's one L actually do so
suppose I'm interested in probability of
h2 equals a lot say to given the
evidence e 2 equals to e 3 ok so this is
the query I'm interested in you know
computing okay so how can I interpret
this quantity in terms of this lattice
right so this is there is this H 2
equals 2 here right that's somehow
privileged and then asking you know what
is the probability of this given the
evidence yeah yeah so sum over all the
probabilities of the paths right so
remember every path through from start
to end is an assignment some of those
paths go through this node which means
that each q goes to and some of them
don't which that means that it's not
true right so if you look at all those
paths and you sum up their weights of
this node and divide by the sum over all
paths then you get the probability of H
2 equals 2 given the evidence ok so let
me just write this this is going to be
sum over colloquially sum over paths
through H 2 equals 2 divided by sum over
all paths ok so now the problem is to
compute the sum over all paths going
through H 2 or not going through H 2
okay again we don't want to sum over all
the paths literally because that's going
to be exponential time so how can we do
this yeah
so what do I mean by some I mean some of
the weights so every path has a weight
which is a product of the weights on the
edges and you some of those ok so what's
an idea that we can use to compute the
sum efficiently programming okay so this
we're gonna do this kind of recursively
let me just show this slide so it's
going to be a little bit different from
the diamond programming that we saw
before it's going to be more general
because we're not computing and let's
say one particular query but I'm going
to compute a bunch of quantities that
gonna allow us to compute all queries
essentially okay so let's there's going
to be three quantities I'm gonna look at
and hopefully I can kind of out of
colors but that's not you screen for
this though so there is going to be you
know forward messages F which I'll
explain a bit there's going to be
backward messages B okay so what I want
to do is for every note I'm going to
compute two numbers yeah no I think I'm
okay what color is that great thanks
okay so let's call this s okay okay so
so for every note I'm going to compute
two numbers one number called the
forward number is or the for message
it's going to be the sum over all the
weights of the partial paths going into
that node and the orange number is going
to be the sum of all the partial paths
from that node to the end okay
so let's let's so these are all meant to
be probabilities so the numbers should
be less than one but just to keep things
simple I'm gonna put actual numbers on
these just two just two integers on them
so they don't have to carry out decimal
points okay so this is one let's say one
two one one two one one two okay so
remember every Edge has a weight
associated with it
and so now let me compute the forward
probability so what is the sum of over
all Pat's going into that note it's just
one right
okay so sorry forward is screen so one
and this is two okay just copying this
and now recursively what is the sum of
all the weights going into this okay so
I couldn't have come from here or it
could have come from here all right so
if I come from here it's one times
whatever the sum was there so that's 1
times 1 that's 1 plus 2 times 2 okay so
I'm gonna get a 5 1 plus 4 and here I'm
going to have 1 times 1 so that's 1 1
times 2 that's 2 so that's going to be 3
hopefully you guys are checking my math
here so what about this notes so now
recursively this could have the paths
going in here could have come from this
node or that node so that's 2 times 5 so
that's 10 1 times 3 and that's 3 so
that's 13 and this is 1 times 5 plus 3
times 2 so that's 11 right okay so 13
represents the sum over all paths going
into H TiVo's okay so I can do the
backward direction
so so this is going to be in orange the
backward messages which are paths going
to the end so this is going to be one
it's here I'm going to have so 2 times 1
plus 1 times 1 so that's a 3 this is 1
times 1/2 times 1 so that's a 3 as well
this is 1 times 3 1 times 3 so that's a
6 this is 2 times that's a 6 and a 3 so
that's a 9 and then I'm done ok ok does
that all make sense so these are kind of
compact representations over the
essentially the flow in and out of the
lattice nodes okay so the they're kind
of the kind of magic happens when I have
these s's so now for every node I'm
going to also just multiply them
together ok so that's going to be 6 18
18 9 13 11 and that's it okay so what
happens when I multiply them together
let's take out the look at this node
right so what is nine represent nine
represents the sum over all the paths
going through here right because I can
take whatever pads I have coming in and
I can take whatever has I have going out
and any sort of combination of them will
be a valid and and path okay and the so
this total weight is yeah so why do we
multiply instead of sum here because
we're multiplying the weight of a path
is the product okay
mathematically what's going on is
exactly factoring right so suppose I
have
numbers let's say a B and C and D and I
could choose a and B and C and D so what
are the possible so then I can do a plus
B times C plus D right which is the sum
over all possible paths and you can dust
paths are either AC ad BC and okay so
I'm basically doing this computing it in
a factorized way rather than expand now
that's mathematically what's going on
when I multiply the four were in the
backward messages and why are these
called messages so the idea of messages
comes from the fact that you can
intuitively think about the former
messages as being kind of sent across
the graph right because the message here
depends only on the neighbors here and
once I get these messages i can compute
the my messages the next time step based
on this so it's kind of a summary of
what's going on and I send the messages
forward and same in the backward
direction okay so now once I have these
values how do I go and back and compute
my query some of our paths through HTTP
goes to what is that nine right and over
the sum of our paths what's the sum over
all paths
sorry this should be 15 I was wondering
this screw anything else up I think
that's right
I was checking because you know when if
you sum these two numbers you get 24
which is all the sum of all Pat's going
through here and that better be the same
number here and also there would be the
same number there right okay so this
should have caught that okay um all
right so these are all the paths going
through nine and I'm sorry going through
this note and if you look at all paths
that's going to be 15 plus nine that's
going to be 24 okay so final answer is
the probability of H 2 equals 2 given
these made-up weights is going to be 9
over 24 any questions about that
okay so let me just quickly go over the
slides which is going to be a more
mathematical treatment of what I did on
the board hopefully one of the ways will
resonate with you so define the former
messages for every node is going to be a
sum over all the values at the previous
time steps of the former message at a
previous time steps times the weight on
the edge from the previous value to the
current value the backward is going to
be defined similarly for every node sum
over all the values assigned to then at
the next time step all outgoing edges of
the backward message at the next time
step times the weight into that next
time step and then define s as simply
just the product of F and B and then
finally if you normalize the sum at each
point in time you can get the
distribution over the hidden variable
given all the evidence and to summarize
the algorithm the forward backward
algorithm is actually a very old
algorithm develop actually first for
speech recognition so while back I think
it's probably in the 60s or so so you
sweep forward you compute all the
forward messages and then you sweep
backwards and compute all the backward
messages and then for every position you
compute si for each eye and you
normalize so the output of this
algorithm is not just the answer to one
query but all the smoothing queries you
want because at every position you have
the distribution over the hidden
variable H I and the running time is n
times K squared because there's n time
steps and every time step you have to
compute this sum so for K possible
values here you look at K possible
values there so that's a K squared and
it's n times K squared interestingly if
you ask okay what's the cost of
computing a single query it would also
be n times K squared so it's kind of
cool that you compute all the queries in
the same time that it takes to compute a
single so question is does this only
work for a hidden Markov models or is it
more general there's certainly add app
tations of this which work very
naturally for other types of networks
and one immediate generalization is if
you have not just a chain structure but
you have have tree structure then the
idea of passing messages along that tree
it's called belief propagation is just
works pretty much out of the box for
arbitrary Bayesian networks this won't
work because you once you have cycles
then you can't represent it as a lattice
anymore any other questions okay so
summarize the slightest representation
allows us to think of paths as
assignments which is a familiar idea if
we're thinking about state-based models
we can use the idea of dynamic
programming to compute these sums
efficiently but we're doing this extra
thing we're computing all the sums for
all the queries at once and the
forward-backward algorithm allows you to
share in a media computation across
different queries so the output of this
algorithm is basically the probability
of H I given all the evidence for every
I owe so how would you actually use this
do you sample from it depends on what
you want to do with it
so the output of this you can think
about it as a distribution at each time
step so it's a n by K matrix of
probabilities right from that you can
sample if you want you can mean you
might all be only interest
in only a various points in time it's
okay so let's move on to the second
ogram which is called particle filtering
so we're interested still in hidden
Markov models all the particle filtering
again is something actually much more
general than that and we're going to
only focus on query filtering questions
so we are filtering we're at a
particular time step we're only
interested in the probability of the
hidden variable at that time step
ditchin on the past and why might we not
be satisfied with hidden Markov or the
forward backward so here's the
motivating picture so imagine you're
doing the car assignment let's say and
you're trying so you're tracking cars
okay
so cars let's say live on a huge grid so
at each position H I the value of H I is
some point on this grid but you don't
know where it is you want to track it
okay so if this is like a hundred by
hundred you know that's ten thousand if
this were thing were continuously would
be even you know worse so this this K
squared where K is the number of values
could be like ten thousand squared and
that's a large number right so even
though hidden Markov a lot of fat with
backward forward backward is not
exponential time even the quadratic can
be pretty expensive and in the further
the motivation is you know you into
Utley shouldn't have to pay that much
right because let's say your sensor
tells you that oh the car is up here
somewhere you know cars can't move all
the way across here so then you know but
the algorithm is going to consider each
of these possibilities
and most of these probabilities are
going to have pretty much zero
probabilities so that's really wasteful
to consider all of them so can we
somehow focus our energies on the region
that have actually hi yeah it's like
fruit the later time steps you can't
have zero in one of those positions the
question is can you go backwards like if
you can't like if your continue to move
one way and you say like it very
unlikely that I'm going to go back to
the starting position do each of those
variables have the same domain I'm
saying oh so each of these variables
they don't have to be from the same
domain for this presentation they're in
the same domain just for simplicity but
I think what you're asking is you know
that maybe a car only moves let's say
forward or something then there is some
restriction on the domain it's not going
to be that significant because you still
don't know where the car is so it
doesn't really cut out that many
possibilities yeah maybe by a factor of
two or something but that's not that
significant okay so how do we go about
making this a little bit more efficient
so let's look at beam search so our
Folio algorithm is not going to be beam
search this can be particle filtering
but beam search is going to give us some
inspiration so remember in beam search
we keep a set of K candidates of partial
assignments and algorithm as follows you
start with a single empty assignment and
then for every position time step I'm
going to consider all the candidates
which are assignments to the first I
minus 1 variables I'm going to extend it
there's possible ways of extending our
setting hi2 V from any V in the domain
of I so now I'm going to amass this set
of extended assignments
now I have K times as may because each
of previous I'm an gothics standing by K
so I'm gonna prune down I'm just gonna
take all of them sort them by weight and
take the top K okay so visually remember
from last time it looks like this so
here is this object tracking where we
have five variables and you start with a
beam search which is assigning X 1 to 0
or 1 and then you extend it so you
extend the assignments you prune down
you extend the assignments you prune
down you extend the assignments have
cleared out and so on and at the end of
the day you get K candidates each
candidate is a full assignment to all
the variables and it has a particular
weight which is its actual weight and
each intermediate time it's a partial
assignment to only the prefix of I
random variables okay and remember that
beam search doesn't have any guarantees
it's just a heuristic but it often it
works while in practice and a picture a
picture you should have in your head is
that you have the exponentially sized
tree of all possible assignments and
beam search is a kind of this pruna
breadth-first search along this tree
which only looks at promising directions
and continues so you don't have to keep
track of all ok so at the end you can
use beam search you get a set of
candidates which are full assignments to
all the random variables and you can
compute any quantities you want so the
problem with this is that it's slow for
the same reasons as I described before
it requires considering every possible
value of H I so it's a little bit better
than forward backward right so for
forward backward you have to have the
domain size times the domain size and
now for beam search
it's the size of the beam times the
domain size now which is better but but
still I think we can do a little bit
better than that and finally there's
this kind of more subtle point as that
as we'll see you later greedily taking
the best K might not be the best thing
to do because you want some maintain
some diversity right just so kind of a
quick visual so suppose you you've beam
consists of only cars over here it's
kind of a little bit redundant but you
might want a kind of a broader
representation okay so the idea with
particle filtering is to just tweak beam
search a little bit and this is going to
be expanded into three steps which I'll
talk about okay so let me does anyone
need this on the board and erase it okay
we're good good look at the video if you
don't remember all right so there's
three steps here okay and we're going to
try to do this pictorially over here so
so the idea behind particle filtering is
I'm going to maintain a set of particles
that kind of represent where I think the
object is so imagine you know the object
starts over here somewhere
so you have a set of particles and I'm
going to iteratively go through these
three steps so proposed weight and
resample so this is meant to be kind of
a replacement of the extent perón
strategy for search okay so the first
step is to propose so at any point in
time particle filtering maintains a set
of partial assignments known as
particles that kind of tries to mimic a
particular distribution so to kind of
jump into the second
we can think about this set of particles
as representing the probability of H 1
and H 2 given the evidence yeah so far
okay on the board I'm only going to draw
the the particle representing the value
H 2 because I it's hard to draw
trajectories but you can think about
really particle filtering maintains this
lineage as well okay so the key idea of
the proposal distribution is that okay
we want to advance time now so we're
interested in H 3 but we only have h 2
so how do we figure out why H 3 is so we
propose possible values of H 3 based on
H 2 so this is idea of proposal we just
simply draw H 3 from this transition
distribution so this remember this
distribution is comes from the hmm this
is your given hmm so you can do this and
this gives us a set of new particles
which are now extended by 1 and this
represents the distribution H 1 H 2 H 3
given the same evidence okay so
pictorially you should think about
proposed as a proposed is kind of taking
each of these particles and sampling
according to the transition so think
about the particle is as you know just
moving in some direction it's almost
like simulating where you know cars are
going and this is done kind of
sarcastically a randomly okay step 2 is
to wait so so far the new locations
really don't represent reality right
because we also see III at time step 3
we get a new observation that hasn't
been incorporated somehow into this
we're just kind of simulating what might
happen and so the idea here behind a
real waiting is for each of those
particles
we're gonna assign a weight now which is
equal to the mission distribution / III
given you know H 3 again this is the
mission distribution which is given by
our hmm so we can just evaluate it
whatever if you like it and the set of
new particles are which are weighted can
be thought of representing this
distribution where now we have
conditioned on III equals 1 okay so now
each of these particles has some weight
so on on this picture it kind of looks
like this so maybe let's say the
emission distribution is kind of let's
say let's say a Gaussian distribution
around the observation so suppose the
observation tells you well it's over
here somewhere
which means that these particles are
gonna get higher weight and these
particles are gonna get lower weight and
if they're far away enough then maybe
they get like almost zero weight so I
I'm going to kind of softly X these out
so think about these as okay maybe maybe
I'll do this
so I'll up weighed these and kind of
start down worried about so nothing
really gets a zeroed out but you can
think about these it's down waiting and
these is up waiting provided you have
let's say some evidence III that tells
you you're going in that direction okay
okay so the final step is it's really
about a resource distribution question
so now we have weighted particles we
need to somehow get back to unweighted
particles okay so which one's it choose
so imagine you have this situation where
you have particles which are kind of
distributed the weights of the particles
are fairly uniform then you could
imagine let's take just the particles
with a highest weight all right this is
very similar to what beam search would
do it would just take all
particles with high weight and just keep
those and nothing else so this is not a
crazy thing to do but it might give you
an impression that you're more confident
than you actually are
right because imagine the the weights
are fairly uniform so maybe this one is
like you know 0.5 and this one is like
point four eight so you're kind of just
breaking ties in a very biased way so
the idea is that if you sample and set
sample from this situation you're gonna
get something a lot more representative
rather than just taking the best okay so
how do you sample from this distribution
so the general idea is if you have if I
this is just kind of useful module to
have if I give you a distribution over n
possible values then I'm gonna draw
let's say K samples from this so if I
have the distribution over four possible
locations with these probabilities or
you know weights then I might draw four
samples and I might pick a 1 and then a
2 and then I may pick a 1 and a 1 so
some of these things are not going to be
chosen if they have sufficiently low
probability okay so going back to the
particle filtering setting we have these
old particles remembering which are
weighted and first I'm going to
normalize these whites to get a
distribution so add these numbers up and
divide by that and then I'm going to
sample according to this distribution
given weights on the previous slide so I
might draw in this case 0 1 1 months and
I might draw it again and might not even
keep this particle and the idea here is
that suppose a particle has really
really low weight as I point 0 users at
1 then I shouldn't kind of
keep it around and because it needs to
occupy memory and after keep track of it
it's basically gone right so this
resampling kind of regenerates the pool
by focusing the efforts on the higher
way particles a might even a very sample
highway particle multiple times and then
not sample the low way particles zero
times okay so in this in this picture
here so resampling might let's see how
do i how do i draw this so maybe now i
have maybe i sample this twice maybe i
sample this twice and maybe these don't
get sample maybe i sample this once
this one's right so so the blue
represent the particles after this one
round of particle filtering where I've
kind of moved the particles over here a
little bit and less away from there so
that's why it's kind of called particle
tracking because you can think about the
swarm of particle is representing where
the object might be and over time as as
I follow the transition dynamics and hit
it with observations I can move this
swarm over time so that's a picture you
haven't you okay so let's go through the
formal algorithm it's going to be very
similar to beam search so you start with
empty assignment and then you propose so
where you take your partial assignments
to the previous I minus 1 variables and
then I'm going to consider for each one
of them just sampling once from this
transition distribution and augmenting
that assignment so unlike beam search
where the size of C prime was K times
larger than C the size of C prime is
equal to the size of C in this case
second irie weight so looking at the
evidence and applying the evidence
probability of evidence given the
particle h i gives me a weight for every
particle and then i'm going to normalize
this distribution
sample que ailments independently from
that distribution and that the
redistributes the the particles to where
I think they're more promising okay so
let's go through this quick demo so the
same problem as before I'm gonna set the
number of particles so 100 so I start
with all the particles assigning X 1 you
know to 0 and there's a hundred copies
of them I extend and notice that some of
the particles go to 0 and some of the
particles go to 1 with approximate
probability proportional to whatever the
transitions are and then going to
redistribute which changes the balance a
little bit and you're going to extend
prune extend by prune I really mean
Riis rewrite every sample and notice
that the particle is kind of get more
dive this is more diverse than well it's
more diverse than beam search because
I'm using K equals 100 rather than like
three but but you can see that some of
these particles might collect my like
this one have zero weight so that when I
resample they just go away yeah so just
to show the brain branching pattern or
is it actually relevant yeah so that's a
good question so notice that all of
these are all of these zero for the
purposes of x4 are just three the same
so if you only care about the marginals
then you can collapse them you're
absolutely right in this demo it's I'm
making the entire histories so that yeah
you can show the see the branch
okay so this is that point if you only
care about the last position and not
about the possible trajectories then you
action actually collapse all the
particles with the same HHI into one and
then furthermore if there's repeats then
you can just keep track of the count
right and this is actually what you
would do in your assignment I'm giving
you kind of the more general picture in
case because particle filtering is more
general than just looking at the last
time step but most of the time your
position so last time so okay so just a
quick kind of quick visual illustration
of this let's define this factor graph
where you have transitions that are
basically 1 or 0 depending on whether H
Y inhi 1 minus 1 aren't close to each
other and oh I is some sensor reading
one thing I've been a little bit
slightly under the rug is sometimes I've
talked about local conditional
distributions sometimes I've been
talking about factors remember from the
point of view of inference it really it
doesn't matter they're all just you know
factors right so in particular if I give
you a factor graph which right remember
which is not necessarily a Bayesian
network I can nonetheless still define a
distribution by simply just normalizing
take all the weights a mult and
normalize and divide by that and these
objects are actually called Markov
networks or Markov random fields which
is another object of study that we're
not going to talk about in this class
but this is actually a more general way
to think about the relationship between
factor graphs and distributions
we're only mostly focusing on Bayesian
networks in this class but some examples
will be more general than that ok so you
have this distribution and so you can
play with this demo in the slides if you
click then this yellow dot shows you the
observation at a particular point in
time and the noise the observation is
related to the true position of some
particle by based on the noise that you
define here
so here I've defined Box noise which
means that it's going to be a uniform
distribution over a box of three by
three by three or I guess a six by six
box and so if I increase the number of
particles to let's say 10,000 then what
I'm going to show you is a red blob that
looks like it's trying to eat the yellow
dot and this red blob shows you the set
of particles where the intensity is the
count of that number of particles in a
particular cell so this swarm I kind of
corresponds to on the board it's the set
of particles but since this is
discretized you can kind of see the
particles piling up on each other and
just to see how well this is doing shofu
position you can see the blue dot is an
actual object position the yellow dot is
the noisy observation and it's trying to
do its best to track where the blue is
it's not perfect because this is kind of
approximate out without about it kind of
gets ok any questions about particle
filtering so to summarize you can do
forward backward if you can swallow
computing a number of domain values
times number of domain values if you
have large domains but you really think
that none of most of them don't matter
then particle filtering is it's a good
tool because it allows you to focus your
energies on the relevant part of the
space okay so now let's revisit gibbs
sampling from a probabilistic inference
point of view so remember gibbs sampling
we talked about last week as a way to
compute the maximum weight assignment in
a factor graph where their main purpose
is to get out of local minimum so
remember how Gibbs sampling works you
have a weight which is defined for
complete assignments so unlike particle
filtering or beam search we're starting
with complete assignments and trying to
modify the complete assignments right
they're trying to extend partial
assignments so you loop and you compute
you pick up a variable X I and then you
consider all the possible possible
values it could take on and you choose
the value with probability proportional
to its weight okay let me show you this
example that we saw last week so so same
graph here so we start with this
complete assignment and then we're gonna
examine X 1 X 1 can take on two possible
values for each of these values I'm
going to compute its weight and remember
in Gibbs sampling I only need to
consider the Markov blanket of that
variable the factors here are Oh 1 and T
1 because that's the only thing that
changes everything else is a constant
and then I was normalized and sample
from that ok so then I go on to an X
variable and so on
so I sweep across all the variables and
eventually the weight hopefully goes up
but not always up because sometimes I
might sample value that has okay and at
the same time I can do various things
like computing the the marginal
distribution over a particular variable
so or if two variables so I can
basically count the number of times I
see particular patterns and I can
normalize that to get a distribution
over that particular pattern ok so
now let's try to interpret Gibbs
sampling from a probabilistic point so
instead of just thinking about Oh a
weight is just a function we can
actually think about the probability
distribution induced by that factor
graph by again summing all the weights
over all possible assignments
normalizing in there you have a
distribution so the way to think about
Gibbs sampling is now more succinctly
and more actually traditionally written
as the following which is you loop
through all the variables and for every
variable you're going to look at the
probability of that variable taking on a
particular value conditioned on
everything else so now we can give like
write down this probability which is you
know a nice way to think about what
Gibbs sampling is actually and the there
guarantee with Gibbs sampling under you
know some conditions which I won't get
into is that as you run this for a long
enough you the sample that you get is
actually a true sample from this
distribution as if you had sampled from
this distribution and if you did that
multiple times now you can actually
compute any sort of marginal
distribution do you like
so now while do is that guarantee sounds
really nice there are situations where
Gibbs sampling could take exponential
time to get there so caveats okay so
let's look at a possible application of
Gibbs sampling image to you so suppose
you have some sort of noisy image and
you want to clean it up so how can this
be helpful so we can model this image
nude denoising problem as this factor
graph where you have a grid of pixel
values and they're connected in this
kind of grid like way so every value of
x I is where I is a location two numbers
is going to be either 0 or 1 and we're
going to assume that some subset of a
pixel
are observed and in case we observe it
then we're actually just going to have a
factor that it's actually a constraint
that says that value of x I has to be
whatever we observed and these we have
these transition potentials that say
neighboring pixels are more likely to be
the same different so it assigns value
to 2 pixels which are the same and 1/2
pixels which are different okay this is
the motto of clear so now let's try to
do Gibbs sampling in this in this model
just to give you an concrete idea of
what this looks like so I'm gonna look
at I'm not gonna draw an entire the grid
but I'm gonna draw center around a
particular know that we're interested
and sampling so there's more stuff away
okay so and remember and get sampling at
any point in time all the variables have
some sort of preliminary assignment so
this might be 1 1 1 and 0 and this might
be 1 ok so now I sweep through and I'm
gonna pick up this variable and kind of
say hmm shall I try to change its value
first of all you ignore the old value
because it doesn't factor into the
algorithm and now you're going to
consider let's say this is X I so X I
there's two possible values here so 0
and 1 right so and I'm gonna look at the
weight so if it's zero then I'm going to
evaluate each of these factors based on
that so remember the transition
potential is well I'm not going to write
down but if let's consider
zero here so these are different that
means I'm gonna get a one these are
different that's going to be a one these
are different that's going to be a one
these are the same and then going to get
a two okay now I try one
these are the same these are the same
these are the same and these two are
different so for every assignment have
this wait so this is two this is eight
and then I normalized so this is going
to be 0.8 and this is going to be 0.2
and I draw flip a coin with heads 0.8
and whatever I get I put down so I might
have with point a probability I put that
one back that's okay and here's another
example which I'm not going to go
through okay so keep sampling it's gonna
do that so now let's look at this
concrete okay so okay so what you're
looking at here is this grid of pixels
white means that the pixel is unobserved
black or red means that it's observed to
be whatever color you see on the screen
and so this is somewhat of a noisy image
and the goal is to fill in the white
pixels so the picture makes sense and
visually you guys can probably look at
this and see the hidden text no okay
okay so you're the noisy system is
pretty good okay so I'm gonna run Gibbs
sampling click and what you're seeing
here each iteration I'm gonna go through
every pixel and apply exactly the
algorithm I whatever I did on the board
okay so you can see that these are just
samples from the set of unobserved
random variables okay so to turn this
into something more
useful you can instead of looking at the
particular sample you look at the
marginal which is for every location
what is the average pixel value that
I've seen so far and if you do that then
you can see a little bit clearer picture
of 220 and while and it's not going to
be perfect because the model that we
have is fairly simplistic it always says
is similar pixels neighboring pixels
hours are tend to have the same color it
has no notion of letters or something
okay but you can see kind of a simple
example of get sampling at work there's
a bunch of parameters you can play with
you can here's a another picture of a
cat you can play around with the
coherence which is how sticky the
transition constraints are you could try
to use ICM which won't work at all okay
any questions make we my action and
earlier today okay so just to kind of
sum up we've last week Monday's we
define new models so we define a
Bayesian network or a factor graph and
today we're focusing on the question of
how do we do probabilistic inference and
for some set of models I've shown you
how to do this there's a number of
algorithms here in a forward backward
which work for hmm and our exact
particle filtering which works for hmm
although they can be generalized which
is approximate and Gibbs sampling which
works for general factor graphs which is
also approximate each of these
algorithms we've seen kind these ideas
in previous incarnations so forward
backward is very similar to variable
elimination because it variable
animation also
computes things exactly particle
filtering is like beam search it
computes things approximately and Gibbs
sampling is like iterative conditional
modes or Gibbs sampling which we saw
from last week okay so next Monday we're
gonna look at how we do learning so up
until now the Bayesian network all the
probabilities are fixed and now we're
going to actually start to do learn it I
should say that maybe this learning
sounds a bit scary because there's
already a lot of machinery behind
inference and factories and all this
stuff but you'll be pleasantly surprised
that learning is actually much simpler
than in France so stay tuned